[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about HUD again so how do
literally means belly power which sounds
kind of like a weird way to describe
something but in general it has to do
with the alignments and the way I used
my body usually we're talking about
creating strength so what makes me very
strong and either when I'm resisting
force or making force how can I use this
how to get in a special way so but how
do you get kind of a blanket term so how
do you could literally be translated as
belly power or the power that comes from
being in front of my belly and that is
to say that my hands work strongest
right here so my hands are in front of
me that's where they work the strongest
and with the most Xterra t as my hands
start to get away from my Center I
become weaker and also much less
dexterous so in order to have the
strongest body alignment I should always
have my hands in front of my Center in
addition to that idea of just my hands
being stronger here and giving me more
dexterity the shorter my arm levers can
be then the stronger I'll be I'm going
to give you an example of that with
Sasha here all right so let me bring
Sasha my arm and I want you to grab
ahold of my wrist and push my arm down
so I'm gonna hold my arm out I'm gonna
resist you strongly as I possibly can
and go ahead and push my arm down and
I'm persisting as hard as I can okay so
at this lever link right so with this
lever right here sausage the burying of
that lever and so I'm someone weighs a
hundred pounds I weigh twice that right
it's hard for me to keep her from
pushing my hand out she has enough
strength to push my hand in if I were to
move in here and she were to do the same
thing at my shoulder when she pushes
down you can see that she can almost
lift herself up on me because I have
enough strength to hold her up like that
right so when she's on the close side of
the lever I'm much stronger apparently
than when she set the long side lever so
this is just basically the principle of
leverage so if sausage sticks your arm
out here like this go ahead oh is this
as hard as I can I'm gonna push your
hand down not very hard okay if I try to
push up here when I push down this is
much harder and that's because this her
arm is working as a lever arm and that
means anything at a clip down here is
gonna be a lot more
for her muscle sort against than
anything I put here the closer I am to
the fulcrum of the lever then the
stronger she will appear to be if when
we bring a device in here so if Josh
brings that pedal down all right so we
have a 35 pound kettlebell here
what's also gonna do is hold it right
here in front of her body like this now
if Sasha were to move it off to either
the right or left you can see she
started to have a really hard time
holding it up she doesn't want to hold
it there very long because it's so heavy
but by making these levers short like
this and holding it right in the center
of her body she's able to hold a much
heavier weight than she would be able to
do otherwise
thank you sighs so the idea here of
honey ghee is that my hands operate
strongest right in front of me right
where my belly is and so by trying to do
everything I'm going to do with my hands
in front I will have the most strength
that I can possibly have this does two
things it puts me in the correct correct
alignment the way I'm built to be to be
working and also shortens my lever arms
then of course I'm having if my arms out
here like this I'm trying to do
something way out here that it's gonna
be way harder than it would be if I keep
my hands in here and that's just simply
where I'm putting the load in relation
to the fulcrum so if I'm lifting from my
shoulder here anything that's in here
that's closer to my shoulder will be
easier for me to live anytime that
weight starts to get away from my
shoulder which is where the fulcrum is
it's gonna be harder and harder for me
to hold so this basic concept of
leverage is key to when we're talking
about how to eat